[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى من ام درمان نتابع هذه الصور
في ظل هدوء الحذر بعد دخول اتفاق وقت
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ وحديث عن تهدئه
حده القتال وتوقف في الطلعات الجويه
للطائرات الحربيه التابعه للجيش
والى كيان هذه الصور المباشره على وقع
ازمه التوغل في بلغارد الروسيه موسكو تتهم
كيف بالطلوع في التوغل والهجمات ونائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول انك لا تاخذ
حروبا على اراضي اجنبيه
الان الى واشنطن ونتابع هذه الصور
المباشره مع توصل المفاوضات بين المشرعين
الجمهوريين وفريق الرئيس جو بايدن بشان
رفع السقف الدين العام في ظل مخاوف من عدم
التوصل الى اتفاق وبالتالي تخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
من تل ابيب الى طهران تصعيد كلامي
وتهديدات متبادله تنذر بمواجهه محتمله
اوامر لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي بالتاهب
ونتنياهو يقول ان اسرائيل تفاجئ ايران
دوما وسوف تفاجئ كل اعدائها ايران تحذر من
اشعال حرب واسعه النطاق وتتوعد لا خطوط
حمراء في ردنا على اسرائيل وحزب الله يقول
انه يمتلك قدرات استثنائيه لخوض اي معركه
تفرض عليه مع اسرائيل
بعدما وصف باخطر توهل في الاراضي الروسيه
منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا
لتصفيه مجموعه مسلحه شنت هجمات في بيل
جورد الروسيه الحدوديه وتقول ان الطائره
والمدفعيه استخدمت فيها هجمات غير مسبوقه
بحجمها على المنطقه كيف تعتبر ما حدث في
بيل جوردن ازمه داخليه روسيه
تقول انها لا تشجع ولا توفر قدرات
الاهتمامات داخل الاراضي الرسمي
في اليوم الاول لخدمه في السودان تمتد
اسبوعا قصف متفرق مع تراجع حده المعارك
واشنطن تقول انها تناقش مع مجموعه مراقبه
الهدنه تقارير عن انتهاكات لوقف اطلاق
النار وتتواعد بمحاسبه ومعاقبه المسؤولين
عن خرق اتفاق جده والامم المتحده تقول ان
الصراع الدال لفرار ربع مليون شخص
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصعيد تل ابيب نبرتها ضد
طهران اذ قال رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي ان
اسرائيل لديها القدره على ضرب ايران كما
قال رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ان
تل ابيب ستحصل على دعم لضرب المنشات
الايرانيه النوويه اذا ما استنفذت كل
السبل
باستطلاعه ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي احتمالات ان
تقدم اسرائيل على توجيه ضربه عسكريه
لايران بالفعل
احد عشر في المئه قالوا بوجود احتمالات
كبيره بينما راى 17% ان هناك احتمالات
محدوده
72% لم يروا اي احتمال مطلقا لتوجيه ضرب
عسكريه بالطائره
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وفي فقره المتابعه نرصد اقمار الاتصالات
ذات المدارات المنخفضه وجه اخر للتنافس
المحمول بين واشتا وبيجين
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من حديثها عن حرب استنزاف تشنها
ايران عليها عبر وكلائها تخرج اسرائيل
بتهديدات مباشره ضد طهران لا مواربه فيها
تتوالى التصريحات من مسؤول اسرائيليا بعد
اخر من رئيس الوزراء وقادته العسكريين
العنوان العريض لا صمت بعد اليوم على
تطورات برنامج ايران النووي طهران بدورها
ترد بلا مواربه ايضا اي استهداف لمنشاتها
النوويه له معنى واحد في قاموسها الحرب
الشامله وحزب الله ايضا على خط السجل يقول
نمتلك قدرات استثنائيه لخوض اي معركه تفرض
علينا مع اسرائيل
يجتمع عقل اسرائيل ليبحث المخاطر
الاستراتيجيه في مدينه هرتزيليا بالتل
ابيب يعقد المؤتمر السنوي الاسرائيلي
يتحدث رئيس اركان الجيش رئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات ومستشار الامن القومي عن
ايران اللغه واضحه والنبره عاليه نقطتان
رئيسيتان يركز عليهما المتحدثون البرنامج
النووي الايراني وتعاظم قوه حلفاء ايران
في الاقليم قلقوا اسرائيل يتزايد بتغير
الظروف الداخليه والخارجيه في الداخل
ينقسم الشارع على نحو لم تشهده اسرائيل من
قبل بسبب التعديلات القضائيه وفي الخارج
تتغير اهتمامات الحلفاء الدوليين وتشهد
المنطقه تغيرات في التحالفات وهدوءا لم
تشهده منذ سنوات طويله تقع تل ابيب جرس
التحذير من البرنامج النووي الايراني تقول
ان ايران تقدمت في تخصيب اليورانيوم على
نحو غير مسبوق تضع الدوله العبريه نسبه
90% لتخصيب اليورانيوم خطا احمر لا يجوز
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه تجاوزه والا فهي
تقترب من انتاج قنبله نوويه ما يعني قلبا
للموازين في المنطقه كلها ترد طهران
بالتاكيد على سلميه برنامجها وانها لم
تتجاوز نسبه 60% في تخصيب اليورانيوم
لكنها في الوقت نفسه اي ايران تحذر من رد
غير مسبوق اذا تقدمت تل ابيب خطوه مؤذيه
الى الامام عين اسرائيل على البرنامج
النووي الايراني دائما لكنها ترى الان ان
الولايات المتحده اهملت ذلك الملف لصالح
ملفات اكثر اهميه لواشنطن التوتر الصيني
مع تايوان وخشيه الامريكيين من تكرار
سيناريو روسيا واوكرانيا الدعم العسكري
والمادي والسياسي والغربي لاوكرانيا لا
يتوقف ولا اولويه تتقدم عليه في المرحله
الحاليه
تجمدت المفاوضات حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني وتوقفت العقوبات الامريكيه
المتعلقه بالامر حتى العقوبات على ايران
مرتبطه الان بتزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمسيرات وفق الاتهامات الاوكرانيه
والامريكيه هذا التغير في الاولويات
الامريكيه بالمنطقه تصاحبه مصالحات تنزع
من تل ابيب ذرائع تشكيل جبهه موحده ضد
ايران اهم تلك المصالحات التقارب الايراني
السعودي وما لحقه من هدوء ملحوظ في ملفات
كثيره هكذا تبدو منطقه خاليه من الازمات
ما عدا التوتر الايراني الاسرائيلي عين
اسرائيل الاخرى على من تصفهم بوكلاء ايران
ينتشر هؤلاء وفق التحليل العسكري
الاسرائيلي في سوريا ولبنان وقطاع غزه
بدرجه اساسيه في اشاره لذلك يقول
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون ان تل ابيب منتبهه
لما تقوم به ايران حول اسرائيل في سوريا
تحذر تل ابيب من انطلاق مسيرات ايرانيه
نحو اسرائيل ما قد يشعل كبرى في المنطقه
وفي لبنان يجري حزب الله مناورات تحاكي
اقتحام مستوطنات اسرائيليه وفي غزه تشير
التقديرات الاسرائيليه الى تعاظم قوه
الفصائل التي باتت علاقتها بايران اقوى
بكثير مما كانت عليه في السابق هكذا تبقى
اسرائيل متاهبه ومحذره وعنوان ذلك التاهب
والتحذير ايران ببرنامجها النووي وحلفائها
في المنطقه لكن التهديد يبقى لغه التخاطب
الوحيده بين طهران وتل ابيب لغه يحذر
الجميع من ان تتحول الى افعال وردود على
شكل حرب
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق سجل التهديدات والتحذيرات قال
نائب الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني
نعيم القاسم ان الحزب مع ما وصفه بوحده
الساحات في مواجهه اسرائيل مؤكدا امتلاك
حزب الله ما سماه القدرات الاستثنائيه
لخوض اي معركه تفرض عليه مع اسرائيل انما
الان الينا من بيروت مدير مكتب الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم اهلا مازن اذا كيف يتفاعل
هذا السجال بين طهران وتل ابيب داخل لبنان
في الواقع ليله يمكن القول بان الكلمه
والعباره المفتاح لفهم الديناميه التي
يتحرك من خلالها حزب الله في لبنان
وايضا من خلالها كامل القوى السياسيه
اللبنانيه ترتبط بالعباره الرئيسيه وهي
معادله الردع التي وردت على لسان النائب
الامين العام لحزب الله قبل ساعات كذلك
وردت على لسان رئيس المجلس التنفيذي للحزب
خلال المناوره العسكريه التي اجراها يوم
الاحد الماضي حين قال هاشم صفيه الدين بان
اي مساس بمعادله الردع القائمه ستؤدي الى
امطار اسرائيل بالصواريخ الدقيقه عمليا
معادله الردع التي يجري الحديث عنها كان
الامين العام لحزب الله خلال الفتره
الماضيه قد شدد عليها وهنا لا بد من فهم
ماذا يعني حزب الله بتعامله مع معادله
الردع هذه المعادله قوسها لم يعد يشمل فقط
لبنان ولكنه بات يمتد على مساحه كبيره
تشمل لبنان والداخل الفلسطيني مرورا
بسوريا والتي يتم استهداف المستشارين
التابعين لحاجه الثوري الايراني وايضا
لحزب الله من قبل الطيران الاسرائيلي
وصولا الى طهران وبرنامجها النووي وهذا
الكلام كان واضحا من خلال كلام سابق صدر
عن الامير العام لحزب الله قبل اشهر عندما
قال بان اي استهداف اسرائيلي لطهران يعني
عمليا بان هنالك وحده ساحات ستفتح ووحده
مواجهه ستفتح من كافه اطراف ما يوصف بمحور
الممانعه وبالتالي التطورات الاخيره التي
شهدناها سواء على مستوى المناوره التي
اجراها حزب الله والتصريحات المواكبه لها
انما تاتي في سياق كان قد بدا قبل اشهر من
خلال الاستهداف المتكرر الاسرائيلي
لمستشاري الحاج الثوري الايراني وحزب الله
في الداخل السوري حينها كان هناك قراءه
لدى حزب الله بان اسرائيل تحاول كسر قواعد
الاشتباك ومعادله الردع وهذا الامر انسحب
من بعد ذلك على اطلاق الصواريخ من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه اسرائيل في الماضي عندما
اطلقت تلك الصواريخ لم يتم تبنيها من اي
احد حزب الله لم يتبناها وايضا الجانب
الاسرائيلي تعامل معها بان فصيلا فلسطينيا
اطلقها ولكن الرساله في التي اطلقت من
جنوب لبنان مع تلك الصواريخ بان هنالك
متغيرا كبيرا وبدانا نسمع بعباره وحده
الساحات التي تحدث عنها النائب الامين
العام لحزب الله اليوم وبالتالي هنالك
معادله جديده تحاول هذه القوى متمثله بحزب
الله وحلفاء في المنطقه مرورا بدمشق وصولا
الى طهران وفصائل الفلسطينيه بارسائها
ولكن ضمن هذه المعادله الكبيره ثم من يرى
في لبنان بان هناك خشيه حقيقيه من اي من
ان اي تدحرج للامور ما بين الطهران وما
بين تل ابيب ستؤدي الى تحويل لبنان الى
ساحه جديده لتصفيه الصراعات الاقليميه من
هنا كان هنالك كلام خلال اليومين الماضيين
لرئيس الحكومه نجيب نقاطي عندما التقى مع
ممثله الامين العام لام متحده في بيروت
وقال بان هنالك رغبه من الحكومه اللبنانيه
بان لا يتم انتقال سيادتها من خلال هذه
المناوره التي حصلت في جنوب لبنان بعجاله
اقول ايضا شدد على ان موضوع السلاح سلاح
حزب الله ينبغي ان يحظى بتوافق لبناني
شامل في حال استخدامه في اي مواجهات في
مقبل الايام اشكرك مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب
الجزيره في بيروت
الان رحب من تل ابيب بضيفنا جولان برهوم
المحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي اهلا بك سيد
برهوم اذن ضمن المعادله الجديده التي كان
يتحدث عنها مازن ابراهيم للتو
هل هناك اي مؤشر يدل على ان هذه التهديدات
الجديده من اسرائيل تختلف عن سابقاتها
بدايه تحياتي وللجميع واشكر ملاكم على هذا
الاستضافه الكريمه انظر
نحن في استعداد دائما كل التصريحات
الاخيره من قبل رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اول مستشار هاني
وخصوصا بالنسبه لرئيس حكومه اسرائيل
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا غير جديد لكن ماذا هو
في نهايه المطاف والامر الجديد الذي قد
تغير في هذه المنطقه
هناك
اغنيه ولكن
انجازات الدبلوماسيه ايرانيه التي تؤثر
بشكل
على دوره اسرائيل
تعلق الاتفاقيات او اتفاق سلام مستقبلا مع
المملكه السعوديه اتفاقيات ابراهيم مصالح
مشتركه ضد ايران اولا وبالاضافه هناك ربما
عدم الاشياء غير مفهومه للاسف الشديد في
اعتقاده هناك مازق سياسي في اسرائيل وهذا
مازق السياسي المشكله السياسيه المعقده
داخل اسرائيل ربما هذه هذا الهدف يؤدي الى
التفكير خاطئ عند الطيران عند المرشد
العالم
وهذا لكن من ناحيه عسكريه استخباريه نحن
على استعداد
الخلاف الداخلي والوضع الهش للحكومه
الاسرائيليه هل فعلا هناك اجماع في
اسرائيل بشان اتخاذ هذه الخطوه اذا ما
اتخذت بالفعل
سؤال ممتاز بدون بدون تحدي لدوله اسرائيل
اجتماعيا ولكن انا اريد ان اوضح الامور
للجمهور المشاهدين الكريم الخلاف داخل
اسرائيل لا يخص بالنسبه لليمين الاسرائيلي
او يسار اسرائيلي هناك اصوات معينه هناك
فئات معينه من اليمين الاسرائيلي لا تقبل
حكم
للتنميه سياسه لان
متهم بملفات الرشوه بسبب
التغيير او الاصلاح القضائي داخل اسرائيل
المهم النقطه هي نقطه قضائيه وما عندها اي
علاقه بالنسبه
للمناطق في يهود والسما رقم انتم تقولون
المناطق الفلسطينيه يهود وثمره الضفه
الغربيه او خطوه معركه مفتوحه او غير
مفتوحه ولكن انا اريد ان اقول واكمل كلامي
واقول انجدي قال غير انا
ان سياسه سياسه دبلوماسيه او مضايقه يعني
نريد ان نضيق على الطهاران بالطرق
دبلوماسيه اقتصاديه عقوبات هذا احسن بدون
شعر نحن لا نريد معركه مفتوحه ولكن اذا لا
يكون اي خيار ثاني اضافي لدوله اسرائيل
فنحن على استعداد بدون شك
شكرا لك غلامنا برهوم المحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي من طهران الان نرحب بضيفنا
عباس خميار الدبلوماسي الايراني السابق
واسالك بدوري عن رؤيه ايران لهذه ولجديه
هذه التهديدات الاسرائيليه وهي المعتاده
ان تسمع هذه التهديدات لفترات طويله
لسنوات في الواقع
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحقيقه اتصور بانه هي هذه هو نوع من
الردود الفعل
ربما
السطحيه التي سمعناها
اليوم من قاده الصهاينه بسبب الاستعراض
العسكري الكبير والفريد الذي قامته
المقاومه يوم امس او قبل يومين وفي نفس
الوقت هي اجابه او يعني
رد فعل على التطورات السياسيه والميدانيه
التي حدثت بما يتعلق بالعلاقات الايرانيه
السعوديه
والسير في اتجاه حل ازمات المنطقه وهذا
نقطه اتصورها بان ذات اهميه كبرى اضافه
الى ذلك العدو الصهيوني يعرف جيدا يريد ان
يعطي العنوان الغلط
لازمته الداخليه والتي
خبر بانه لا سابقه لها على مدى الاحتلال
خاصه في السنوات الاخيره بسبب
الانهيار الكبير الذي يحصل في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وهذا ما يتحدث عنه القاده
الصهاينه بكل اطيافهم والوانهم
واتجاهاتهم الوضع الذي تحدث عنه
هذا الوضع تحديدا الهش الذي تعيشه الحكومه
هو اللي قد يدفعها لتتخذ خطوه ربما لتحاول
ان تنقذ نفسها لذلك الاستهانه ربما بهذه
التهديدات من جانب الايراني اكيد تاخدها
تنظر لها على الاقل بعين الاعتبار ولكن
السؤال ما هي ادوات الردع والرد لدى ايران
فيما يتعلق بهذه الهجمات اذا حصلت لا لا
هذا هذا لا عفوا اسمحي لي ان اقول هذا ليس
انقاذ نحن في اللغه الفارسيه نقول يخرج من
الحفره ويقع في البئر اذا اراد الكيان ان
يخرج من حفرته ومن ازمته هو سيقع في
الازمه كبرى ربما تكون يعني تقترب من
نهايتها وهذا ما يحصل فعليا
الايرانيون قادرون بقوتهم
وبالتحامهم
بوحدتهم
وبقدرتهم ان يواجهوا هذا التهديد هذا
التهديد لم يكن تهديدا جديدا قد سمعناه
على مدى اربعين عاما من الكيان الصهيوني
واشكال مختلفه اليوم كما اشرتم يعني موضوع
وحده الساحات هذه نقطه اساسيه ولا يستطيع
احد ان ينكر هذه
المعادله الجديده وقدره الردع التي
تواجهها الان يواجهها الكيان الصهيوني
اضافه الى ذلك اختي الفاضله يعني
الاسرائيليون هم اخر من يستطيعون ان
يتحدثون عن يعني
الالتزامات النوويه والمشروع النووي هم
يملكون ترسانا نوويه كبيره ولا يعني
ينتمون الى ولا ينتمون الى اي اتفاقيه
دوليه والى اي
مؤسسه عالميه تؤطر هذه العلاقات اشكرك
عباس
الايراني السابق من شكر
[موسيقى]
اخر اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه القضاء
على من تبقى ممن وصفتهم بمجموعات القوميين
الاوكرانيين الذين هجموا مقاطعه بلغارد
وابعاد من تبقى منهم الى داخل اوكرانيا
ونقلت وكاله عن السلطات المحليه الروسيه
تاكيدها مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه عشر اخرين
في الهجمات على المقاطعه وكان حاكم قال ان
عشرات المباني تضررت وانقطعت الكهرباء عن
اربع عشره قريه وذكر ان السلطات الروسيه
اجلت مدنيين من تسع بلدات على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا
وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انه تم صد الهجوم على بلجورد وهزيمه
المجموعات الاوكرانيه من خلال الضربات
الجويه ونيران المدفعيه كذلك
عمليه مكافحه الارهاب تم صدو هزيمه
التشكيلات القوميه من خلال الضربات الجويه
ونيران المدفعيه والعمليات النشطه للوحدات
الحدوديه ما ادى الى مقتل اكثر من 70
ارهابيا اوكرانيا وتدمير اربع عربات قتال
مصفحه وخمس شاحنات صغيره
وفي المقابل اكلت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني انا مليار انا بلادها لا تقوم
باي عمليات داخل الاراضي الروسيه واشارت
مليار الى ان من يقف وراء الاحداث التي
تشهدها مقاطعه مواطنون روس مستاءون من
نظام بوتين بسبب حربه على اوكرانيا على حد
تعبيرها منذ برشه
بطريوتو وفق فهمنا فان هؤلاء هم وطنيون من
روسيا من الاشخاص الذين تمردوا بالفعل على
نظام بوتين كان من المفترض ان يؤدي ذلك
لما يحدث الان في منطقه بلغرود الوضع في
بيلجرود هو ازمه روسيه داخليه نحن لا نقوم
باي عمليات على اراضي روسيا نحن نحرر
ارضنا ضمن حدودنا المعترف بها دوليا
ونعتبر تلك المنطقه الحدوديه منطقه خطر
اما منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي فقال ان
واشنطن لا تشجع ولا توفر اي دعم للهجوم
على الاراضي الروسيه وفق تعبيره
لا نملك في الوقت الحالي معلومات كثيره
حول هجوم بيليكرود في روسيا ويبدو ان
مجموعات روسيه متعاطفه مع اوكرانيا تقف
وراء هذه الهجمات المزعومه داخل وحولها لا
نعرف بالضبط دوافع تلك المجموعات او كيفيه
قيامها بذلك من الواضح اننا لا نشجع ولا
نوفر اي دعم للهجوم على الاراضي الروسيه
وتركيزنا منصب على التاكد من ان اوكرانيا
يمكنها الدفاع عن اراضيها
هذا وقد شهدت الاونه الاخيره تزايدا في
الهجمات التي تستهدف العمق الروسي تنوعت
هذه الهجمات ما بين هجمات صاروخيه او
هجمات بالطائرات المسيره المفخخه او توغل
مجموعات مسلحه الى الداخل الاراضي الروسيه
هجمات في العمق الروسي تقول موسكو ان
بصمات الجيش الاوكراني جليه عليها
تنفيكييف وتقول انها من فعل مجموعات
معارضه لحكم بوتين وبتتبع مسار هذه
الهجمات نلحظ تصاعدا في عددها وقواتها
وجراه اكبر في اسلوب تنفيذها مقاطعه
بيلكرود على بعد اربعين كيلومترا شرقي
الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه هنا كانت اكثر
الهجمات دمويه حين فتح مهاجمان النار داخل
معسكر تدريب للمتطوعين الراغبين في القتال
باوكرانيا اوقع احد عشر قتيلا وبمرور شهور
الحرب تحولت مقاطعه بيلجرود ومعها مقاطعه
بيريانسك الواقعه على بعد 60 كيلومترا من
الحدود مع اوكرانيا هدفين لهجمات صاروخيه
وعلى فترات متفاوته اوقعت قتلى وجرحى
الطائرات المسيره اكثر جراه من الهجمات
الصاروخيه بعد ذلك في الهجوم على الكرملين
بدايه الشهر الحالي بطائرتين مسيرتين
بينما اعلنت الطوارئ الروسيه العثور على
مسيره ثالثه مفخخه في ضواحي موسكو كذلك
الهجوم على ماطرين عسكريين في منطقتين
على بعد مئات الكيلومترات من ساحه المعركه
في اوكرانيا واسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه جنود روس
اما التوغل داخل الاراضي الروسيه فهو
سيناريو توبع مرات عده منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا حدث ذلك في بيريانس حين تسللت
مجموعه مسلحه الى احدى قرى المقاطعه
الروسيه واحتجزت رهائن داخل احد المتاجر
اما اخطر عمليه تسلل فكانت خلال الساعات
الماضيه حين اقتحمت مجموعتان مسلحتان
بالقرود وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها
تصدت للهجوم وقتلت عشرات من المهاجمين وقد
اعلن ما يعرف بفيلق حريه روسيا مسؤوليته
عن الهجوم في بيلجرود الروايه نفسها تجزم
بها المخابرات الاوكرانيه بالقول ان
الفيلقين روسيين معارضين للكرملين هما
فيلق حريه روسيا وفيلق المتطوعين الروس
ينفدان عمليه داخل بالقرود لانشاء ما
تسميه كييف منطقه امنيه لحمايه المدنيين
الاوكرانيين
كبير الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه كلوبسات
للدراسات اهلا بك السيد لدوج
ما خطوره ما حدث في
بامكاننا ان ننظر الى هذا الامر على مستوى
واط من المساله
التكتيك العسكري وهو القتال المستوى
الاعلى وهو المستوى السياسي بالتالي
المستوى المنخفض ان هذه كانت ربما مجموعه
من عده مئات من المسلحين الذين قاموا بشكل
هزموا بشكل سريع من الكلمه القول ان بعضهم
كانوا مسلحين باسلحه غربيه ربما اتت من
مدرعات غربيه او مصدرها غربي هذا جانب
بامكاننا ان نتذكر وهذا ربما نرتفع فيه
الى المستوى السياسي الى الامور التي قام
بها الروس في دوناسك
والقرم ايضا
بقله من الجنود الذين هم انكروا انهم جزء
من الجيش الروسي لكنهم في حقيقه الامر
افراده في الجيش في عام 2013 هنالك عنصر
اخر حول كيفيه سمحت القوات الروسيه بحدوث
مثل هذا الامر وهذا السؤال يوجه لوزير
الدفاع وهو سيطرح من قبل الشعب الروسي
بالتاكيد
ومن ثم الرد الروسي هنا ما الذي يمكن ان
نتوقعه ماذا بعد
هذا سؤال وجيه في بالكورد نفسها يبدو ان
هنالك مجموعات مسلحه
متمرده هي ليست معروفه لكن هنالك معلومات
قليله متوفره حول تم الحاق
الهزيمه بهمه ومن وجهه نظر الروسيه هم
يتساءلون متى سيحدث هذا الامر مره اخرى
وايضا خاصه بوجود القواعد الروسيه على بعد
قريب منها لكن ما الخطوه التاليه هل سيتم
هنالك تصعيد من قبل الروس ساجيب بالقول
انه ليس من الواضح ما هي خياراتهم
المتوفره ليس هنالك الكثير مما يستطيعون
القيام به في اوكرانيا لا يقوم به اصلا
لا احد يلوم الغرب او اي دوله غربيه على
ما حصل بالتالي نتساءل عن خيارات روسيا
ولا ارى الكثير متاحه الان تقول ليس هناك
اكثر من ان تفعله داخل اوكرانيا هل يمكن
ان تفكر في خطوه خارج اوكرانيا مثلا
نعم لا استطيع حقيقه رؤيه هذا الامر هنالك
مؤشرات حتى بين الاكثر
تطرفا من
الذين الناشطين في الانترنت وايضا في دول
اخرى مثلا من دول النيتو
اعتقد انه اذا مكانه هنالك اي معلومات عن
تورطهم قد يكون قد يتم الاعلان عن ذلك قد
يلوم اوكرانيا عفوا ما حصل اوكرانيا
بالتاكيد تقول انها عرفت هذا الامر لكنها
ليس لديها اي علاقه بهذا الامر كما حصل في
القرن قبل سنوات لكن بالعوده الى سؤالك
انا في حقيقه الامر انا لا ارى اي خيارات
للروس بالنسبه للتسعين اعتقد انهم سيفضلون
ان ينسوا هذا الامر ان لديهم امور اهم يجب
ان يقلقوا عنها اشكرك فرانك كبيره خبراء
العسكريين في مؤسسه كلوب ساك للدراسات
شكرا جزيلا
الان الى السودان
البلد الذي شهد تراجعا في حده المعارك في
اليوم الاول من الهدنه لقد افاد مراسل
الجزيره بوقوع اطلاق نار متفرق في منطقه
المهندسين
وهنا اطلب من ضيفي هنا
الالتحاب جنوب مدينه ام د ام درمان غربي
الخرطوم كما رصد صباح اليوم اطلاق نار
متقطع من اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه وتحليق
للطائرات غربيه الخرطوم جاء ذلك بعد ساعات
من بدء سريان اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار وهو
الاول الذي سيخضع لمراقبه وسط التفاوت
اما في مدينه الاوبيض غربيه البلاد فقالت
مصادر محليه ان الهدوء عاد الى المدينه
والتي شهدت ضواحيها مناوشات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش صباح اليوم ووفق
المصادر فقد استمر اطلاق النار نحو ساعتين
مما ادى الى نزوح معظم سكان حي السكه
لمناطق امنه
ضيفي الذي استعنت به قبل قليل معي الان في
الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني اهلا وسهلا يا هلا بك
اذا هذه الهدنه هل مصيرها سيختلف عن ما
حصل في اتفاقيات سابقه برايك هل ما يدل ان
الالتزام بها مختلف هذه المره قد تكون
المنشورات الاوليه تقول بان الالتزام بها
مختلف ولكن المعطيات الميدانيه توضح بان
هنالك عوامل معقده قد تهدد استمرار هذه
الهدنه خاصه ان هنالك عدم سيطره بالنسبه
لي قوات الدعم السريعه على معظم القوات
التي تقاتل معها في مناطق متفرقه من
الخرطوم وواضح من خلال السلوكيات العسكريه
والميدانيه ان هذه القوات لا تخضع لاداره
وسيطر من قبل قياده الدعم السريع فهي
ترتكب كثير من التجاوزات التي لا اعتقد
انها ستصوف في مصلحه الدعم السريع خاصه
وان الدعم السريع يريد ان يحسن صورته امام
المجتمع الداخلي والمجتمع الخارجي فمثل
هذه في مثل هذه الاوضاع لا نستطيع ان
نراهن بان بالامكان ان تستمر هذه الهدنه
الى فتره زمنيه طويله
كل طرف الان يحضر نفسه لما بعد انتهاء
الهدنه ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه من الطرفين
ما الاوراق التي يحملها والتي تجعل فعلا
فرص حقيقيه للخروج بنتيجه مختلفه
على هذا المستوى المتعلق بالاتفاقيات واقع
الميدان وتداعيات الاعمال العسكريه هي
التي ستحدد المالات فبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
الهدنه او ما تم الاتفاق عليه سيكون له
تاثيرا كبيرا على مجريات الاحداث هنالك
معطيات مهمه في الواقع الميداني هنالك
انتشار كبير لقوات الدعم السريع خاصه في
الاماكن المدنيه الان الدعم السريع لم يعد
خطرا عسكريا على سكنات الجيش وعلى مقار
الجيش ولكنه اصبح خطرا امنيا على
المواطنين عبر عمليات السلبي والنهب
والاغتصاب والعمليات المختلفه والمتفرغه
التي تقوم بها الدعم السريع فبالتالي هذه
المعطيات لا اجد في فيما تم الاتفاق عليه
ما يحيد منها خاصه وان هنالك دعوه او
مطالبه بانسحاب هذه
القوات من الاعيان المدنيه ولكن الاتفاق
لم يحدد الى اين هذه القوات هذه القوات
التجات لهذه الاعيان المدنيه لتحتمي من
الطيران وبالتالي هي اذا لم تجد امانا في
اماكن اخرى لا اعتقد انها ستستجيب خاصه
وان الاليات المرتبطه بالارض اليات
المراقبه والتحديث هي ليست متوفره الان
هنالك حديث عام مراقبه عبر الاغمار
الاصطناعيه ولا اعتقد انها مجديه وذات اثر
كبير فيما يتعلق بتداعيات الاوضاع حتى
اليوم الذي يعتبر الافضل مقارنه بالهدن
السابقه هنالك تجاوزات حدثت وهنالك
اشتباكات حتى خارج العاصمه في منطقه
الاوبيد كما اشرطه قبل قليل في التقرير
فهذا الواقع المعقد المتداخل والمتحرك وفق
المحطيات الميدانيه لا اعتقد ان هنالك
حاسم له ومحدد لمسارته سوى تداعيات
العمليات العسكريه في الميدان وماذا عن
الدور
الوساطات هنا يعني الضغوط التي تمارس على
الطرفين هل فعلا
تختلف هل فيها شيء جديد هنالك تحذيرات من
الاداره الامريكيه بانها لها وسائل للضبط
المراقبه
الاختراقات وانها لها عقوبات ولكنها لم
تكشف عن طبيعه هذه العقوبات خاصه كما قلت
قبل قليل هذا الانتشار الواسع الفوضوي
لغوات الدعم السريع يجعل من الصعوبه
الامساك بتحركاتها وتحديد مساراتها وتحديد
افعالها على الميدان وهذا يلاحظ من خلال
ما تنقله وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من
اهتداءات سافره على الاعيان المدني
المستشفيات وعلى مساكن المواطنين وعلى
عمليات النهب
الان الخرطوم الحديثه تنهار تماما معظم
المستشفيات تحت الاحتلال العسكري معظم
المدارس هدمت الجامعات
الاماكن المختلفه البنوك نهبت كل المكونات
الدوله الحديثه في الخرطوم الان تنهارت
تماما وفقا لهذا نعم
جزيلا
الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني وفي الواقع انقل نقطه اثرتها
بشان الموقف الامريكي والادوات التي
تمتلكها كان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
بمعاقبه من ينتهك التهدئه الجديده التي
ابرمها طرف الصراع في السودان
من المفروض في هدنه الايام السبعه التي
تسري اليوم ان تتيح ايصال مواد الاغاثه
واصلاح الخدمات الاساسيه والبنيه التحتيه
ان الاتفاق نتيجه مسعا دبلوماسي محموم
وشراكه وثيقه بين السعوديه وولايات
المتحده واذا خلق وقف اطلاق النار فلن
يخفى ذلك عنا وسنحاسب المسؤولين عن
انتهاكه بالعقوبات وادوات اخرى طوع ايدينا
من الولايات المتحده لا تدعم حكومه
ديمقراطيه لا تقصي احدا فالحكومه المدنيه
هي وحدها القادره على النجاح في بسط
الاستقرار والامن
ومن جانبه حضر السفن دوجري كان متحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده من احتماليه
ان يكون الصراع الدائر في السودان
تاثير ان يكون له تاثير اقليمي اذا لم يتم
ايقافه كما اشار الى سعي الامم المتحده
لتوسيع عملياتها الانسانيه في البلاد
ومن بستنى ينضم الينا الان
السفير الامريكي السابق في السودان اهلا
وسهلا بك سفير كارني واريد ان اسالك عن
الادوات التي تتحدث عنها واشنطن فيما
يتعلق بالوضع السوداني ما نوع هذه الادوات
اعتقد انه ربما
النقطه المهمه هي ما هي الادوات التي سيتم
استخدامها من اجل مراقبه الالتزام بهذه
الهدنه ضيفكم اقترح ان الاقمار الصناعيه
لن تكون فعاله وانا اوافقه الراي بالتاكيد
ان هذه ليست الطريقه المناسبه لكن فان
الولايات المتحده باستخدامها للمسيارات
بامكانها ان تؤمن القوافل والتي اخرجت
هنالك تقاطع في الصوت
مراقبه خروج اكثر من الف شخص من
بورتسودان اعتقد ان المسيرات ستكون اكثر
فعاليه في مراقبه الاوضاع على الارض يجب
في نفس الوقت ان يكون هنالك
قوات مثلا من السعوديه ومن امريكا ومن
اطراف اخرى قد تكون جزء من قواته الدعم
الدوليه يجب ان يكون
مقرهم في السفاره الامريكيه وهي في منطقه
مؤمنه ومعزوله من الخرطوم
ادوات اخرى لديها متوفره لدى الولايات
المتحده وزير الخارجيه تحدثت عن العقوبات
اعتقد انه قد نبحث عن هذه الكلمه الاساسيه
وتفسير ما الذي تم توافق عليه في وعقوبات
بحق من في هذه الحاله يعني العقوبات بحق
من برايك
وشكلها
نعم نعم كنت ساتطرق الى ذلك الامر اذا ما
صبرت قليلا الفقره الاخيره تحدثت على ان
الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه طالبت الجنرال لاين
بالتعهدات التي قطعوها لعقد ذلك الاتفاق
هذه هي اقوى لغه رايتها في
النصوص
الدبلوماسيه لوصف الوضع
كان هنالك حديث اكثر عن العقوبات العقوبات
اذا قد نظر الى حسابات بنكيه وفقيود على
السفر لكن عذرا ساقطعك هنا اذا سمحت لي
اذا سمحت لي في النهايه هل يمكن القول ان
هناك تحول في الموقف الامريكي حيال الازمه
حيال الهدنه هل تقرا فيها شيء
اكثر شيء لفتاه انتباهي ان الولايات
المتحده تزداد صرامه في مساله النظر الى
موقف اجنالين والكارثه التي الحقوها
بالبلد وشعبه اشكرك جزيلا السفير تمثيكار
السفير الامريكي السابق في السودان
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه قال الرئيس
حزب النصر التركيه المعادي للاجئين اميت
اوزداد ان حزبه لم يتوصل بعد لقرار بخصوص
الجهه التي سيدعمها في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره في 28 من
الشهر الجاري واضاف استاذ في مؤتمر الصحفي
في انقره انه سيجتمع بزعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ومرشحي تحالف الشعب كمال كلشتار
اغلو الليله وذلك لبحث عدد من المسائل
العالقه بحسب تعبيره
هذا ويواصل افراد الجاليه التركيه في
الخارج الادلاء باصواتهم في الجوله
الثانيه ففي المانيا فتحت اليوم اكثر من
مركز فتحت مراكز الاقتراع في ولايات برلين
وبراندا
وذلك لليوم الثاني على التواليء
لتصويت الذي يستمر حتى يوم غد الاربعاء
ويحق لنحو مليون ونصف مليون تركي في
المانيا التصويت في هذه الانتخابات
وبعد اعلاني مرشح تحالف الاجداد سنان
اوغان دعمه لاردوغان
وترقبا لحسم رئيس حزب النصر اوميتوزا
موقفه من دعم كمال كلجد فان تحالف الاجداد
قد تفكك فهل يتحكم اوغان بالاصوات التي
حصل عليها في الجوله الاولى نتابع هذا
التقرير
سنان اوغان اسم سلطت عليه الاضواء في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه سطع نجمه
بحلوله ثالثا في الجوله الاولى وهو موقع
شرع له ابواب الطموح السياسي والحزبي
وقربه من منزله القاده البارزين بعدما
توارى في السنوات الماضيه اثر خروجه من
حزب الحركه القوميه صاحب السته وخمسين
عاما اكاديمي من اصول تركيه اذربيجانيه
حصل على شهاده مانشستر في القانون المالي
والمصرفي من كليه الاقتصاد والعلوم
الاداريه بجامعه مرمره ثم على الدكتوراه
من جامعه موسكو الحكوميه للعلاقات الدوليه
في روسيا عمل بعد ذلك استاذا في معهد
الدراسات التركيه بجامعه مرمره ثم محاضرا
في مؤسسه الدراسات التركيه العالميه
باذربيجان كما عمل في المركز الاوراسي
للبحوث الاستراتيجيه ليؤسس بعد ذلك في عام
2004 مركز العلاقات الدوليه والتحليل
الاستراتيجي ويعد من اشهر مراكز التحليل
والتفكير في تركيا بدات المسيره السياسيه
لاوغان في حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2011
يومها اصبح نائبا في البرلمان عن الحركه
كانت علاقته جيده بزعيم الحركه القوميه
دوله بهجلي لكنها تصدعت بعدما دعم بهجلي
سياسات اردوغان لاسيما بعد محاوله
الانقلاب عام 2016
توجه دفع شخصيات بارزه في التيار القومي
الى التحالف ضد قياده الحركه القوميه
وكان سنان اوغان رابعهم اخفق الاربعه في
الاطاحه بدوله بهجله من قياده الحركه عام
2016 بسبب خلافات داخليه في مؤتمر الحزب
تعرض اوغان للترد مرتين من صفوف الحزب
لكنه عاد بعد كل مره وفي استفتاء عام 2017
لتغيير النظام السياسي التركي من برلماني
الى رئاسي
قرار الحركه القوميه التصويت لصالحه ولم
ينتسب بعد تلك السنه لاي حزب سياسي عاد
اسم الرجل بقوه الى الواجهه باعلان
التحالف الاجداد للتوجهات القوميه
اليمينيه ترشيحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
انقضت جولتها الاولى بحصوله على المركز
الثالث محققا مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت
وبنسبه
خمسه.17
نسبه شكلت مفاجاه ودفعت بتحليلات وتساؤلات
عما اذا كان اوغان يتحكم بهذه الاصوات ام
ان اغلبها كان نقمه واعتراضا على سياسات
تحالفي الجمهور والشعب معا اوغان وضع
شروطا عاليه مقابل دعم احد المرشحين
للجوله الثانيه قبل ان يعلن دعمه لاردوغان
الذي قال انه لم يتفاوض مع اوغان للحصول
على دعمه
[موسيقى]
ونتوقف في فقط المتابعه هذه الليله عند
شكل من اشكال التنافس المحموم بين
الولايات المتحده والصين وتعلق الامر
باطلاق اساطير مما تعرف باقمار الاتصالات
ذات المدارات المنخفضه يوجد ما يزيد على
اربعه الاف قمر اصطناعي من ذلك النوع تدور
في مدارات قريبه من الارض وتعرف باسم
الابراج الفضائيه
وتشغل شركه سبيس اكس لصاحبها الملياردير
الامريكي الى الماسك شبكه واسعه تشكل
وتشغلها من تلك الاقمار الاصطناعيه تحمل
اسم ستارلينك وتعمل على ارتفاع
549 كيلومترا عن سطح الارض
اكلت تلك الشبكه من الحفاظ على تمكنت من
الحفاظ على اتصالات الانترنت عاليه السرعه
في اوكرانيا وذلك بالرغم من
تلف البنيه التحتيه للاتصالات السلكيه
واللاسلكيه هنا ويعتقد كثيرون انها تستخدم
ايضا لاغراض عسكريه وذلك
كتوجيه هجمات الطائرات المسيره
الصين التي يتقدم برنامجها الفضائي بمعدل
اسرع من اي دوله اخرى تسعى لمنافسه شبكه
الامريكيه بانشاء نظامها الخاص من اقمار
الاتصالات منخفضه المدار تعمل احدى
الشركات الصينيه الخاصه على تطوير صواريخ
لنشر ما يصل الى 60 قمرا اصطناعيا
للاتصالات في عمليه اطلاق واحده كانت هناك
تسريبات للبنتاجون مؤخرا اشارت الشهر
الماضي الى ان بيجين لا تكتفي بمحاوله
المنافسه انما تعكف على تطوير هجمات
الكترونيه بهدف عرقله الاتصالات العسكريه
عبر الاقمار الاستثنائيه
طبعا وسط تصاعد التوترات الجيو السياسيه
ياخذ هذا التنافس الامريكي الصيني على
ارسال اقمار اصطناعيه الى مدارات المنخفضه
حول الارض ياخذ ابعاد مختلفه
تعمل فرقه في القوه الفضائيه الامريكيه
على انشاء اسطول من تلك الاقمار الصناعيه
وذلك لدعم الاهداف العسكريه
اما الصين التي تمتلك نحو 700 قمر اصطناعي
في المدار فقد توسعت في تصنيعها مع دخول
شركات جديده مملوكه للدوله وشركات ايضا
تابعه للقطاع الخاص الى هذا المجال
الاتحاد الاوروبي من جانبه شرع في تطوير
شبكه ذات مدار ارض منخفض وذلك كجزء من
استراتيجيه اتصالات فضائيه
وذلك بالرغم من ان هذه الشبكات باهظه
التكلفه فان الدول والشركات الكبرى تستثمر
في انشائها وذلك بسبب عوائدها الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه وفوائدها العسكريه كذلك
الان ينضم الينا من الدكتور مارك
وهو استاذ الدراسات الدفاعيه ومدير ابحاث
امن الفضاء في جامعه كينج في لندن اهلا
وسهلا بك دكتور
في اطار السجال والتنافس المحموم بين
بيجين وواشنطن اين تصنف هذا التنافس
الفضائي يعني في اي خانه تضعه من حيث
الاهميه ومن حيث الغلبه حتى الان
بدايه الفضاء هو اساسي للمجتمعات الحديثه
بشكل مختلفه مثلا هنالك
والتلفاز الذين نتحدث خلاله وكل هذه
الامور تعتمد على الفضاء في الجيش مثلا
الاتصالات والملاحه وجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وتحديد مثلا مناطق كل هذه
مهمه استخدم الفضاء بها
البلد الذي استثمر بشكل اكبر في الفضاء
وبالتالي هو يعتمد على شكل على الفضاء
بشكل اكبر هي الولايات المتحده بالتالي
الولايات المتحده تتاثر بشكل كبير على ما
يحصل في الفضاء الشيئ الاخر الذي يجب ان
نتذكره ان الاقمار الصناعيه هي حساسه
للغايه تتاثر بالضوء والامور الاخرى
بالتالي النسبه هذا الامر يجعل الولايات
المتحده تتاثر بشكل اكبر مقارنه بالدول
الاخرى التي تستخدم الفضاء نرى الفضاء
هنالك منافسه
الحرب البارده هنالك في نفس الوقت فائده
اقتصاديه كبيره وايضا مثلا توفر امكانيات
البث التلفاز وامور اخرى بالتالي قد تفوق
قد يكون
عسكري كما حصل في الحرب البارده او انه
يكون تفوق تجاري بالتالي قد لا يكون هنالك
السيطره لكن هنالك سعي للامكان الدوله
معينه مثل الولايات المتحده والصين او اي
دوله اخرى تكون قادره وان تستمر باستخدام
الفضاء بالطريقه التي تخدم مصالحها يعني
لطالما سمعنا هذا التعبير الفضائي يتسع
للجميع ولكن هل الفضاء المنخفض يختلف يعني
هل هناك فعلا من يملك السيطره على الفضاء
الالكتروني هنا
ساقول انه اذا ما اردنا ان
نفكر في عدد
الستلايتات او الاقمار الصناعيه راينا
سيكون هنالك الولايات المتحده مثلا ولكن
نظام ستار لينك هنالك
بالتاكيد الولايات المتحده لديها اكبر عدد
من الاقمار الصناعيه وربما ايضا
الامكانيات الصين تقوم بتطوير امكانياتها
بنفس الطريقه التي قامت بها الولايات
المتحده وهي تقلل من الفرق عدد الاقمار
الصناعيه لك من الصعب السيطره على الفضاء
من مفهوم العسكري عندما نفكر السيطره على
الاجواء مثلا الفضاء مختلف من الصعب
بالسيطره على الفضاء اعتقد انه هنالك
قد يكون مثلا اذا ما اردنا مثلا اعاقه
الاقمار الصناعيه قد يكون هنالك ركام او
ركام فضائي قد يعيق عمل الاقمار الصناعيه
لدوله معينه يعني ذكرت اكثر من مره ان
الغلبه حتى الان هي للتكنولوجيا الامريكيه
ولكن نعرف ان التكلفه الصينيه المنخفضه
سواء في تطوير يعني تصنيع هذه الاقمار
الاصطناعيه وتسييرها في الفضاء هل يجعلها
فعلا منافس شرس هنا هل تقترب من يعني هذه
الغلبه الامريكيه لتضعها في الماضي قريبا
اذا هم يقللون من الفرق بالنظر لانهم
يستخدمون نفس التكنولوجيا التي تستخدمها
الولايات المتحده وانت محقه نعم انهم
لديهم امكانيات لتصنيع الامور والاشياء
بكلفه اقل ما هو مهم ان اللاعبين او
الاطراف التجاريه قد قاموا بتخفيض كلفه
الانتاج مثلا راينا مثلا سبيس اكس تقوم
باطلاقها عدد كبير من الاقمار الصناعيه في
اطلاق واحد وفي المجره في انحاء مختلفه من
المجره وهذا الجانب التجاري اعتقد انه
نسميه نسميه بالفضاء الجديد له تاثير كبير
في زياده عدد
الاقمار الصناعيه وامكانيات اطلاقها بكلفه
اقل بالتالي في هذا السياق فان هذه معركه
معركه الكل فاذا ما استطعنا تسميتها هي
تفوز بها شركات التجاريه الامريكيه الان
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور ماركلبون استاذ
الدراسات الدفاعيه ومدير ابحاث امن الفضاء
في جامعه كيمز قادش من لندن
[موسيقى]
والان نختم باحد اشكال العنف ولكن من
القاره الافريقيه هذه المره تقول السلطات
في الكاميرون ان متمردين انفصاليين خطفوا
نحو 30 امراه وذلك اثناء مشاركتهن في
مظاهره ضد الانتهاكات التي ارتكبت في غرب
البلاد حيث يدور نزاع دام منذ نحو ست
سنوات حدث ذلك في منطقه شمال غربيه
الكاميرون حيث تقدم الجماعات الانفصاليه
المسلحه في كثير من الاحيان على خطف
المدنيين للمطالبه بالحصول على فديه
السلطات تقول انه لا توجد اخبار عن
الرهائن وتضيف ان هؤلاء النساء المسنات
نظمنا مسيره سلميه للاحتجاج على عمليات
ابتزاز وانشطه اجراميه
المدنيون دوما يدفعون الثمن خصوصا الفئات
الاكثر هشاشه يدفعون ثمن هذه النزاعات
والامل كل الامل ان تعود النساء المحتجزات
الى بيوتهن في الكاميرون وغيرها اشكركم
على المتابعه
[موسيقى]